bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 78 lactu on
fera comme tous les soirs de la semaine
le tour de l'actualité locale et en ce
mercredi 15 janvier on commence avec
cette image celle d'une salle debout on
va la voir voilà pour saluer celui qui a
été pendant 16 ans président de l'lom
étion de 50 ans ieline Robert Cadalbert
et qui a annoncé qu'il ne poursuivrait
pas son mandat après des élections
municipales du mois de mars cétait donc
hier soir mardi au théâtre de
SaintQuentin en ivine à l'occasion de la
cérémonie des vœux un moment assez fort
Robert Cadalbert bonsoir vousêtes grand
plateau ce soir avec nous vous avez
ressenti quoi quand vous avez vu
justement cette salle se lever forcément
une très grande fierrté une satisfaction
vous
savez un territoire comme Saint-Quentin
Livine sa réussite son développement
c'est une affaire collective et de voir
effectivement toute cette salle qui
était archipleine effectivement
approuver l'ensemble des des de mes
propos et féliciter se féliciter je
dirais de leur travail de la réussite de
saint-quanttin vin ça fait toujours un
moment plutôt de plaisir tout à fait
alors vous restez en plateau avec nous
on va revenir sur sur cette cérémonie et
puis sur ce sur votre annonce donc hier
soir au Théâtre de Saint-Quentin je vous
propose de regarder ce reportage tourné
avec Patrick Jacques de
dixm une standing ovation pour saluer le
départ de celui qui est depuis 16 ans
président de l'agglomération de 50 ans
Yveline quelques instants plusutôt
Robert Cadalbert l'a confirmé lors de la
cérémonie des VE j'ai pris la décision
après avoir mûement réfléchi de ne pas
continuer à assumer la lourde tâche que
représente la mission qui m'a été
confiée il y a maintenant 16 ans je sais
que les enjeux de demain encore plus que
par le passé vont mobiliser une énergie
dont un homme de mon âge à la sagesse de
penser qu'elle se trouve d'abord dans la
jeunesse c'est un passage de relais
comme dans le sport le témoin se
transmet dans la dynamique en
l'accompagnant jusqu'à la main qu'il
reçoit je serais donc fidèle à mon poste
jusqu'à la fin de mon mandat Robert
Cadalbert élu à guilloncour avait pris
la suite de Roland nado ancien maire de
la commune et je me souviens d'ailleurs
avoir cité cette parole d'évangile il
faut que je diminue pour que lui il
grandisse et il a grandi maintenant euh
la page se tourne il y a eu vous le
savez beaucoup d'échanges euh je pense
que c'était très bien que Robert
Cadalbert et il a dit avec ses mots et
et avec j'allais dire sa personnalité
euh rappelle qu'il avait beaucoup
réfléchi et dans la réflexion il y a eu
aussi beaucoup d'échanges bien sûr à 69
ans Robert Cadalbert quittera donc dans
quelques mois la vie politique pourtant
en septembre dernier il avait annoncé
qu'il se sentait prêt à repartir
quelques mois plus tard le discours a
changé bah il a changé qu'on aille
changer les uns les autres je pense que
la décision que j'ai prise aujourd'hui
est une bonne décision bonne décision
dans l'intérêt de Tin lvin et bien sûr
dans l'intérêt que je sens pour moi-même
c'est un choix personnel c'est plus là
on n'est pas sur des des positionnement
politique c'est pas lié à des des des
jeux politiques c'est pas du tout là
c'est des choix personnels de de vie de
de on fait le le bilan on tire les
conséquences aussi de de de ce qu'on a
envie de faire de sa vie enfin après
c'est c'est très on est dans le registre
de l'intimité aussi hein il y
aurait-il des pressions et un
arrangement qui aurait été trouvé au
sein de la gauche pour ce renouvellement
c'est
effectivement une hypothèse pression ou
pas agglomération qui basculerait à
droite aux prochaines élections ou
resterait à gauche en tout cas c'est une
page qui se tourne à 50 ans en Yveline
et les regards sont aujourd'hui tournés
vers l'avenir l'histoire sera différente
Robert Cadalbert avait su améliorer la
gouvernance à Saint-Quentin ouvrir aux
communes de droite et j'espère que les
résultats de toute façon des élections
municipales sur les SEP communes de
sa-quanttin va décider d'une nouvelle
majorité si c'est à droite Jos spéis que
le président issu des rangs de droite
ira dans cette direction peut-être la
Meur encore si c'est quelqu'un issu de
la gosse je craint que ça se politise un
peu plus les antinois devront attendre
la fin des élections municipales en mars
pour connaître la composition de la
nouvelle équipe qui dirigera
l'agglomération quant à Robert Cadalbert
69 ans il souhaite s'investir dans
d'autres projets le fonctionnement du
Vélodrome la rider Cup 2018 le soutien
de la candidature de la France pour les
Jeux Olympiques de 2024 et le projet de
Grand Paris c'est Normandie
oui alors Robert CAV je voudrais d'abord
revenir sur les raisons de de votre
départ effectivement en septembre
dernier vous aviez dit lors d'une
conférence de presse que vous étiez prêt
à repartir et que vous seriez présent
sur list de gauche à Guill encour alors
entre septembre et janvier il y a eu
comme vous l'avez dit des échanges des
réflexions oui bien sûr mais le choix
c'est un choix personnel aussi c'est un
choix d'abord dans l'intérêt de satinine
de ses habitants et de l'entreprise que
représente cette grande épopée de cqutin
niveline pour ma part vous savez on ça
fait plus de 16 ans que je suis
président de
l'agglomération 30 ans que je suis élu
sur les territoir de 5 en Yveline on a
toujours des pages qu'on veut tourner
des projets qu'on veut mener à bien il y
en a certains que je continuer à mener à
bien et effectivement on a discuté dans
l'intérêt de saint-quentinvin comment
effectivement à la fois ce vaisseau qui
est saint-quentinvin continue à être sur
la voie de la réussite et je pense ce
que j'ai dit hier ma première décision
c'est que les engagements qu'on a pris
pour satinv la réussite de sainttinville
est est parti et effectivement bien sur
les rails ça c'est important pour moi et
quand par exemple Alex le maire de de
voisins de brotonneux évoque des
pressions euh vous répondez quoi parce
qu'on se doute quand même que votre
décision même si elle est liée à quelque
chose d'intime elle est forcément
politique aussi oui mais dans le sens le
plus noble du terme de la politique
c'est comment faire en sorte que les
projets au service des habitants de les
entreprises de Saint-Quentin puissent
avancer et je pense qu'on a montré
l'exemple Saint-Quentin est une réussite
et si c'est une r c'est parce que c'est
un travail d'abord collectif donc c'est
normal que on travaille collectivement à
la suite aussi de saintqutinvine et dans
les dossiers qui existent il y a
quelques dossiers vous les avez rappelés
dans votre reportage qui m'importe de
continuer à les impulser vous savez
quand on est président de
l'agglomération la première chose qu'on
a c'est d'avoir une vision d'être le
capitaine d'avoir une vision et
d'entraîner et cette action d'entraîner
un groupe qui amène à la réussite de
CTIN vine ça effectivement ça se discute
collectivement même si on discute savoir
quels sont les dossiers qui est
important comme ceux effectivement de la
rider C
aujourd'hui je travaille déjà à la
délégation comment on va aller à à Glen
Eagle en septembre 2014 donc on est
vraiment dans dans la
continuité on a comprisa il y avait
effectivement beaucoup de dossiers qui
vous qui vous intéressaient après les
les municipal savez toujours on a on
peut penser qu'on est indispensable les
dossiers heureusement personne n'est
indispensable dans dans dans dans dans
dans ces dossiers c'est d'avoir une
affaire collective alors vous allez
continuer à siéger il faut le lire quand
même là même si vous avez fait l'annonce
officielle de votre départ hier lors de
la cérémonie des vœux vous allez
continuer à siéger à la présidence de la
communauté d'agglomération jusqu'à la
fin mars oui bien sûr non j'assumerai
comme je l'ai dit mon mandat jusqu'au
bout je ne demande pas un nouveau mandat
mais j'irai jusqu'au bout de ce mandat
là et donc jusqu'à la convocation
puisque c'est le président en exercice
qui convoque le futur conseil issu des
élections du du 30 mars mais on aurait
pu imaginer que vous auriez pu passer le
relais avant euh comme par exemple
Jacques lolos l' fait à Manil les hameau
ou piercellincour à la verrière on peut
tout imaginer mais on est quand même
dans une démocratie et le passage le
plus normal jeis c'est quand même celui
des élections donc aujourd'hui
effectivement j'ai décidé de le passer
au moment des élections et dans ce
cadre- làà effectivement la discussion
qui a porté puisque vous posiez cette
question là elle était comment je passe
le relais j'avais annoncé parce que vous
dites oui mais en vous av j'ai annoncé
je voulais passer la main donc un des
dossiersoute pas pas aussi vite hêtement
le le dossier qui m'importait de tenait
à cœur d'aller jusqu'au bout celui que
j'ai porté comme celui du Vélodrome
c'est celui de la Raider Cup et donc ce
dossier C est-ce que c'était mieux que
j'aille jusqu'en 2018 pour porter
complètement l'AR de C ou que je discute
quel moyen je peux continuer à animer ce
dossier de la rider Cup voilà un des des
questions alors qu'on l'appelle c'est
pas une des des pressions c'est
simplement une vraie discussion dans
l'intérêt d'abord du territoire pour que
ce territoire continue à réussir alors
vous êtes élu depuis 30 ans sur le
territoire présent de l'agglomération
depuis 16 ans c'est toujours un peu
compliqué de répondre à une question
comme ça mais quel est le dossier dont
vous avez été le plus
fier un dossier non compliqué il y a
beaucoup de dossiers qu'on est on a
beaucoup CELI qui vous a pe-être marqué
ben le dossier on est le plus fier quand
même c'est la réussite économique de sa
et l'emploi sur 5antine vous savez quand
quand je saluais le nouveau directeur du
centre de safran qui était là pour la
première fois au vœux parce que le
centre de recherche de saintfran excusez
peu 45000 m² VO donc écoutez c'est pour
moi c'est un bel exemple de la réussite
quand j'ai porté quand même la fin de
l'opération
d'innational avec et la rentrée dans une
nouvelle opération d' internationale
Paris saclé ben écoutez sa France
installe c'est parce que on est sur
l'opération d'intérêt national Paris
saclé je pense que je peux être fier
d'avoir porté ce projet de développement
du cluster est à contrario est-ce qu'il
y a un dossier où vous dites oh c'est
dommage je suis pas allé jusqu'au bout
je pense par exemple à
l'intercommunalité élargit parce que
demain les intercommunalités devront
être plus importantes on le sait mais
sur
l'intercommunalité il y a un
développement normal c'est celui du
plateau de saclé c'est pas moi qui a
inventé l'opération d'intér naationale
et donc tout le monde pas d'accord tout
le monde est pas d'accord sur ce sur ce
sur cette orientation vers plate
heureusement tout le monde n pas
d'accord mais on confronte les
effectivement l'intercommunalité doit se
faire dans un projet j'ai toujours dit
sur un projet par contre si j'ai un
regret bah c'est CELI peut-être de pas
avoir eu les Jeux Olympiques si je dis
aujourd'hui que il faut qu'on soit
candidat à aux jeux
olympiquesut faut pas parler de revanche
mais vous savez on apprend on a de
l'expérience et mon souci c'est de
transmettre expérience et c'est vrai que
ça a été quand même une déception de pas
pouvoir organiser les Jeux Olympiques à
50 excusez du peu quand même mais voyz
on a le
vélodrome on a tenu les engagements que
j'ai pris devant Paris 2002 12 ont été
tenus le vélodrome est là et c'est un
excellent équipement et ça sera un très
grand succès et c'est un très grand
succès populaire comment vous voyez la
communauté d'agglomération dans les
années à venir ou même dès le mois de
d'avril parce que en fait les les modes
de scrutin va quand même changer
beaucoup la donne puisque les
conseillers communautaires ne seront
plus élus par leurs père mais par les
les électeurs directement à travers le
bulletin de vote lors des municipal
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que ça
peut changer l'équilibre politique en
2008 droite et gauche était quand même
coude à coude il faut voir quand même il
y a s de l'histoire le sens de
l'histoire c'est l'intercommunaité c'est
ensemble on fait plus ensemble au niveau
de l'Europe on fait plus que voyez bien
le on est rentré làut on ne peut dire
tout ce qu'on ve dire sur l'Europe c'est
un grand succès cette Europe imaginez
qu'elle soit pas là et ben l'intercomité
c'est la même chose au niveau local
c'est ensemble avec les communes alors
il y a eu des ha bas rappelez-vous il y
a pas si longtemps que ça certains
c'était le Parti communiste cétait
retour à l'autonomie communale d'autres
voulaient deux villes nouvelles une de
riches une de pauvre une à donc vous
vous êtes toujours sur la ligne de
consensus hein puisque vous vous aurez
été un président consensuel quand même
peut-être mais c'est pas le consensus
pour le consensus c'est pour
qu'effectivement on débouche on avance
dans l'intérêt général de tous et je
pense que c'est un outil le consensus
c'est un outil au service de du projet
al ça c'est peut-être le conseil au
prochain ou à la prochaine présidente de
l'agglomération oui des conseils au
moins transmettre l'expérience d'accord
je voudrais marquer une pause dans cette
édition et vous faire réagir ensuite
nous allons écouter Benoît amamont hein
c'est le Ministre de l'économie sociale
et solidaire c'est aussi et surtout j'ai
envie de dire le député de la 11e
circonscription des ivelines et bien il
a confirmé officiellement hier soir au
micro de TVfil qu'il sera bien candidat
au municipale à trpe on l'écoute
fondations qui ont été posées par Robert
Cadalbert bah à nous de faire en sorte
qu'ell soit demain encore plus utile à
faire en sorte qu'il y ait moins de
chômeurs sur le territoire de
l'agglomération qu'on continue à avoir
un développement économique qui mélange
à la fois l'excellence et en même temps
des métiers de tous les jours maintenant
on verra ce que seront les résultats des
élections municipales
tout cas j'ai l'intention avec d'autres
de m'inscrire dans la continuité des
décisions qu'il a prise I Je sa candidat
aux élections municipale à trpe j'ai
l'intention de siéger à l'agglomération
mais parce que je pense que c'est non
seulement un territoire important mais
que les compétences qui sont celles de
l'agglomération sont importantes et que
développement de ce territoire quand je
dis développement de ce territoire la
vie des gens qui habitent m'intéresse
alors si
demain élu attrape et élu à
l'agglomération est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose selon vous pour
l'agglomération écoutez que des hommes
comme des femmes politiques de
l'envergure de benoî amammont qui quand
même ministre qui s'est engagé sur
teritireon on le connait bien et puis il
porte quand même un projet au niveau
gouvernemental excusez du peu sur la
consommation sur l'économie sociale
solidaire on peut être fier que les
choses avancent et donc que des gens de
qualité viennent à saint-quantting
honore notre territoire de de toute leur
capacité à agir à faire avancer les
choses on peut peut que être réjoui
est-ce que benoî Hamon ferait un bon
président de
l'agglomération je sais certainement
qu'il en a il en a toutes les qualités
après savez l'expérience ça ça je sais
pas si il y a 16 ans on aurait pu dire
est-ce que je pouvais être un un bon
Président on vous a eu la réponse par
laovation qu'on m'a fait donc
effectivement un moment de plaisir mais
au départ on met le pied à l'étrier
Benoît hont est-ce qu'il était
normalement un bon ministre on voit bien
il réussit dans ce qu'il entreprend en
tant que ministre je suis certain qu'il
entreprendra des choses intéressantes
aussi sur 5 yvelin dernière question
Robert Kelberg est-ce que vous allez du
coup vous allez pas mener campagne pour
ces municipales puisque vous êtes
candidat sur aucune liste malgré tout
est-ce que comment vous allez vous
impliquer comment le président de
l'agglomération va s'impliquer vous
allez soutenir les uns les autres vous
avez des préférences écoutez ça fait 30
ans que je vous dis je suis élu à
saint-quentinine je porte un projet de
gauche mais collectivement on porte un
projet de gauche qui réussit excusez du
peu hein et réussit économiquement et
avec leurs trois piliers
économie cadre de vie
solidarité je pas changer ma façon de
voir surtout quand les choses
réussissent comme C à 50 vous verra sur
le terrain pendant ces municipal je suis
toujours présent d'abord dans mes dans
mon mandat avec mes fonctions et en plus
dès que effectivement si on vient sur
TVfil pour faire un débat je suis
toujours partant pour débattre parce que
la vie politique c'est des débats des
idées et puis après on passe aux actes
et je montrer que on était capable de
montrer aux actes après il peut y avoir
des changements on n pas forcément
d'accord sur tout hein voyez bien sur le
vrome on n' pas fait l'unanimité et
pourtant le VROM est là c'est une grande
réussite et j'espère que ça sera une
très grande réussite populaire merci en
tout cas Robert cadabert d'être venu sur
le plateau du 78 actu et donc vous je
rappelle que vous avez annoncé hier que
vous ne serez plus vous ne seriez plus
président de l'agglomération à partir de
mars prochain en tout cas vous ne
continuez pas votre mandat merci
beaucoup d' ven surite pas un nouveau
mandat oui tout à vous finissez votre
mandat mais vous ne sollicitez pas en
tout cas un nouveau mandat allez on
continue ce 78 actu avec une autre page
politique cette fois on va aller du côté
de voisin le Bretonneux et du côté de la
droite trois listes sont en LCE celle du
mer sortant Alexis Biet celle
d'Alexandra Rosetti l'ancienne adjointe
et celle de Jean-Louis tison sur le
plateau de municipal 2014 Jean-Louis
Tizon avait lancé un appel à Alexandra
Rosetti je vous propose de le réécouter
c'était il y a tout juste un mois
Alexandra Rosetti elle est courageuse
elle a des convictions elle a payé ses
convictions elle a été isolée moi je
sais ce que c'est aussi que d'être isolé
en politique on se retrouve sur beaucoup
de sujets par exemple elle a pas voté
pour le vélodrome moi je n'aurais pas
voté pour le vélodrome si j'avais été au
Conseil Communautaire récemment donc moi
effectivementement avec je l'invite je
l'invite à ce que nos listes se
réunissent voilà ben finalement les
listes ne vont pas se réunir puisque la
principale intéressé Alexandra Rosetti
nous a confié hier soir qu'elle ne fera
pas d'accord avec Jean-Louis tiison il
n'aurait pas trop trouver de terrains
d'entente en ce qui concerne notamment
la tête de liste allez direction
maintenant l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin hier mardi donc se tenait
un nouveau conseil d'administration afin
de voter le budget 2014 il a été accepté
par le Conseil mais rejeté par le
recteur car présenté en déséquilibre de
7 million d'euros ce qui est contraire
au Code de l'éducation et bien
l'université a maintenant un mois pour
présenter un nouveau budget je vous
propose d'écouter la réaction de
Jean-Luc vessiard c'est président de
l'université maintenant on va rentrer
dans une phase de négociation avec le
ministère puisque un Bud équilibre c'est
un peu innovant le ministère s'est
engagé à nous accompagner dans notre
plan de retour à l'équilibre sur
plusieurs années à priori 3 ans donc
voilà donc le ministère va nous aider en
terme de trésorerie pour pouvoir aller
progressivement vers l'équilibre mais
voilà il s'est pas engagé à nous mettre
plus d'argent comme ça donc ce sera
peut-être des avances remboursables
ultérieurement quand la situation sera
rétablie voilà j'aurais pu pas présenter
de budget laisser le recteur faire ce
qu'il voulait faire des couples mais je
pense que c'était être responsable que
de présenter ce budget être responsable
vis-à-vis du ministère responsable par
rapport à ma communauté donc et par
rapport aux étudiants aussi mon objectif
c'est de pas aller pas faire de coupes
supplémentair ou vraiment très
marginalement voilà donc l'université a
jusqu'au premier mars pour présenter un
nouveau budget un nouveau budget qui
devra être en équilibre un tout autre
sujet si vous habitez plaisir vous avez
peut-être vu de la fumée s'échappé d'un
bâtiment près de l'hôpital Charco alors
pas d'incendie à déclaré pour autant il
s'agit en fait d'un exercice au feu réel
les sapeurs pompiers du secteur de
plaisir ont pu s'entraîner dans des
conditions réelles clercambier et lodim
moine étit ce mardi à leur côté à
plaisir les pompiers s'activaient pour
éteindre cet incendie dans un bâtiment
désaffecté pas de panique il s'agissait
d'un exercice pendant une semaine 84
sapeurs pompiers ont bénéficié d'une
formation continue en conditions réelles
une opportunité assez rare au cours de
leur formation initiale et au cours de
le leurs entraînements les jours de
caserne ils font tout par partie ils
font la technique de lance ils font de
la reconnaissance ils vont faire du
traitement des fumées aujourd'hui ça
permet de mettre tout en action au même
moment donc en fait c'est plein de
petites techniques plein de petits
outils qui travaillent au quotidien
qu'aujourd'hui peuvent mettre en action
sur un feu réel et en
simultané les sapeurs pompiers doivent
s'introduire dans ce dédal de couloir
combattre le feu et secourir les
éventuelles victimes une équipe reste à
l'extérieur en soutien en tenue rouge
les formateurs observent leur
comportement attention une sonnerie
retenti signe que la bombonne d'oxygène
est vide exerci non ce pompier doit
sortir quelques minutes plus tard la
manœvre se termine bilan les objectifs
sont ATS le est éteint la victime a été
retrouvé secouru en par les équipes
extérieur pour les formur reste tout de
même à améliorer retour c'est qu'il y a
encore du travail à faire notamment sur
la progression et l'attaque de fumée
c'est quelque chose qui n pas forcément
abordé dans les dans différents guides
et puis bah la pratique a rien de mieux
pour pour justement après le rendre le
rendre sur intervention les stagiaires
pourront continuer à s'exercer tout au
long de la journée si manœuvre total ce
bâtiment désaffecté appartient à
l'hôpital Charco son personnel de
sécurité a pu profiter également de
cette opportunité on a pu aussi se
connaître entre les agents de sécurité
de l'hôpital charcoot et les pompiers de
plaisir s fac si demandons intervenir on
a on se connaîtra mutuellement on se
fera con confiance mutuellement et aussi
jeurais passé les messages importants
des des informations dont nous on a
besoin lors de nos interventions un
système gagnant gagnant en France les
incendies causent la mort de près de 800
personnes chaque année allez la kisomba
vous ne savez peut-être pas de quoi il
s'agit et bien c'est une danse cousine
du tango originaire d'Angola un stage a
été proposé à trppe clair campier
Anthony
r prenez la position câlin et c'est
parti pour une
kizomba cette danse importée d'Angola se
caractérise par sa langue
on appelle un peu abusivement la kizomba
du tango africain parce qu'on retrouve
déjà la même posture un peu en pyramide
donc
vraiment vraiment l'un contre l'autre et
les déplacements aussi on retrouve des
déplacements qui sont liés au tango
argentin tout simplement la kizomba est
vite venu concurrencer les rythmes
latino-américains comme la salsa et la
bachata sur le bord de la piste cette
danse semble simple mais en pratique
c'est une question de sensation entre
les deux partenaires qui s'affinent à
chaque pas effectué je pratiqu un tout
petit peu avant et j'ai en fin de compte
la kizumba on pense que c'est assez
simple et j'ai plein de défauts dans ma
danse et là je me suis aperçu qu'avec
les profs ils m'ont corrigé plein de
défauts donc on croit que c'est la
kisonba c'est c'est facile mais c'est
quand même assez dur donc je galère
quand même pas mal la kisomba moi je
dirais connexion je crois que c'est le
mot le mot idéal étant donné que c'est
le mot qu'on utilise vraiment tout le
temps qui veut vraiment signifier non
pas simplement un contact physique entre
les deux partenaires mais un feeling et
un échange en quelques cours vous
pourrez apprendre les bases qui vous
permettront de vous amuser sur les
rythmes angolais pour ce type de stage
de découverte de 2 he il vous en coûtera
€ allez on reste à trpe avec be the one
battle la première édition d'une
compétition de danse Hipop qui a réuni
plus de 500 personnes à la merurise la
France contre la Belgique 3 2
32 danseurs internationaux se sont
retrouvés samedi à la meurise de Trapp
strict hip hop crée l'événement et
organise be one battle la première
édition d'une compétition de danse en
trois catégories break Hipop et Crump un
genre venu d'outre Atlantique très
populaire dans l'univers de la danse
Hipop le bre c'est plus un style
artistique où voilà il y a des y a des
mouvements au sol en l'air voilà c'est
plus ça se rapproche un peu plus de la
gym voilà et le hiphop c'est plus des
mouvements debout avec des fluidités et
le Crum c'est c'est c'est une question
d'attitude en fait c'est du debout aussi
mais c'est une question d'attitude c'est
c'est c'est une mentalité faut avoir en
fait les danseurs s'affrontent un contre
un ou deux contre de selon la catégorie
sur une musique freestyle du DJ il y a
du bon son il y a un bon public il y a
des jeunes il y a des vieux il y a des
bébés il y a tout donc voilà c'est
vraiment c'est mixte c'est un partage
c'est un échange de de d'une autre
culture pour des gens qui qui pratiquent
pas et voilà franchement c'est c'est
super honnêtement c'est super technique
originalité le danseur faut qu'il faut
qu'il se dne quoi s'il fait rien bah jée
il va paster pour lui bien qu'il
s'agisse d'un show le battle n'en est
pas moins une compétition les
performances sont évaluées par un jury
de professionnels moi je note pour la
danse ça veut dire l'expression
l'échange de l'énergie avec l'autre donc
si euh tu partages plus bah pour moi tu
peux plus me séduire qu'autre chose
partager en rigolant surtout s'amuser
sur le son s'amuser sur la musique et
s'amuser avec son adversaire c'est plus
important la différence en fait c'est la
maîtrise la maîtrise de son de son style
justement et de sa technique en fait
toujours nourrir la flamme du hip hop
les mecs toujours les danseurs pourront
à nouveau s'affronter le 15 février à
l'occasion du Jam battle contest une
compétition par équipe de break dance
initiée par strict Hipop depuis
maintenant 4 ans
wou quelle souplesse allez cette lact
est terminé merci de votre attention
dans quelques instants vous retrouvez le
kiosque l'émission culturelle présenté
par Aurelia de B demain retour de
l'actualité en direct à 18h avec Wifred
rich bonne
soirée